I have been dismantling problematic
Wellness content for over 10 years so if
you're ready to dive into the dumpster
fire Vault with me here are some of the
most jaw on the floor memorable moments
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
if you guys are new here welcome we got
a lot of catching up to do but I had
this Pinch Me moment recently when I
realized that I have been doing this job
for over 12 years I recently shared a
Roundup of some of my most memorable
what in a day moments and as I was doing
the research I was honestly overwhelmed
with the crazy content that I have seen
I have posted over 4 000 videos so as we
say here there's a lot to unpack so my
last video I focused more on the what
Aina day moments today I want to focus
on some of the serious what the
died advice that I've come across here
on this app buckle up folks and Trigger
warning there is a lot of problematic
diet tips ahead so please do skip this
video if it's not supported to your
journey also a reminder that this
content is not fresh so a lot of these
content creators or celebrities may have
grown in their food Journeys and
honestly I definitely hope that they
have I don't even know if some of these
people are even posting content anymore
so as always this content is not meant
to bully or shame so please be kind in
the comments but yeah the YouTube space
has changed so so much over the years
and I myself have grown a lot in my
Approach and tact but again this is just
a gentle reminder of the permanency of
the internet and why we really do need
to be prudent about what we post
especially if we hold a lot of power and
clout and finally don't forget to hit up
my description for my free Hunger crush
and combo ebook Okay folks get those
diet culture Bingo cards ready
let's dive in here starting with another
Gem of a diet tip from The Cheetah Girl
Adrian from All Things Adrian you want
your body to be a
BO2 a newborn baby as possible
pure when they're first born that is why
every time they eat something they go to
the bathroom right after now I also want
to note about Adrian's suggestion that
we should be going to the bathroom as
often as a newborn babies in order to
cleanse ourselves lose weight and
achieve the same Purity as babies uh
no first of all babies go to the
bathroom more often not because they're
pure but because they're digestive
organs like the stomach esophagus and
intestines are substantially smaller
than that of an adult a one week old
newborn stomach is about the size of an
apricot or Plum so it can actually only
hold about three to four tablespoons of
liquid obviously then they have to feed
like every hour or so and they poop
pretty regularly newborn baby's guts are
also immature as they are actively
building digestive enzymes and healthy
gut bacteria hence why we don't give
newborns green juice or avocado we give
them breast milk or formula only so it
does not make sense to compare the
inputs and outputs of adult humans to
babies when these systems are
developmentally very very different I
also want to touch on Adrian's
recommendation that we should be going
to the bathroom an hour after eating a
meal while drinking something like green
juice May or may not give you the runs
the time it takes for one meal to move
through your stomach and intestines can
take anywhere from one to three days or
more and this is necessary and important
in order for nutrients from food to be
efficiently digested and absorbed by the
body before excretion if you were to go
to the bathroom immediately after a meal
you may be bypassing critical steps in
digestion and absorption and missing out
on important nutrients from food and a
super Speedy Transit through the
digestive system is often the case with
things like diarrhea which is perhaps
the only time when you'll find yourself
running to the can in the hours
following a meal and I think we can all
agree that this is no fun for anybody
and speaking of not so much fun I want
to talk about the hack from the now
deleted Blair walnuts video about
letting your friends eat all the tasty
food when you're eating out as a diet
hack when I'm out and I order a side of
mac and cheese and I share with my
friends that's another if I have you
guys share with your friends let them
eat most of them so I think it's always
great advice to share food with friends
but ordering a small side of mac and
cheese for the table and having your
friends consume most of it so that you
can create the facade of participating
in the social foodie fun without eating
more than a few dozen calories is
problematic and since we're on the topic
of low calorie let's take a look at this
tidbit from Julianne Hough celery juice
or something that also gives me a little
bit of sugar before I go do a quick
workout or I'll do like amino acids or
something like that to just give me that
support that energy that I'm looking for
Wow Wow so many problematic statements
in like five seconds of footage
okay first of all I would never
characterize celery juice as a source of
sugar to energize your workout
there's literally one gram of carbs in a
stalk of celery one a banana in contrast
which would be a very very modest
pre-workout snack and also not something
that I would characterize as super high
in carbs and sugar has 30. so please
let's stop the carb shaming crap here
second branched chain amino acids are
exactly that amino acids the building
blocks of protein and as such they are
also not the most efficient source of
energy and since we're on the topic of
amino acids I just want to remind
everyone that if you're consuming enough
protein from Whole protein sources or
even from like a protein powder there's
no need for additional BCAAs or Branch
chain amino acid supplements they also
contain so few calories AKA energy
because that's what calories are that
they are not going to be very good fuel
for a hard workout either because I know
my kids would fight over anything that's
not equal it's only fair that we also
share a tip from the other Huff sibling
Derek so we start out with lemon water
it's a little bit of like warm lemon
water to revitalize and just energize
our bodies Revitalize energize hypnotize
and mesmerize
it helps with hydration too so we're
almost getting hydrated drink this first
thing in the morning get your gets
everything going get something moving
and then don't eat anything for the next
for 15 minutes so let everything kind of
sink in absorb your body rock and roll
alkaline energize because the lemon even
though it's acidic when it goes in your
body it turns alkaline
do your job Abby
just do your job
all right so although Studies have shown
that lemon juice may make the pH of our
urine more alkaline that this does not
have any effect on the pH of our blood
in fact no food has an effect on our
blood pH because if it did we wouldn't
have any Wellness influencers on
Instagram because they would all be dead
next it is my friend but since we are on
a liquid breakfast kick let's talk about
the Smoothie tip from pharmacist Dr Mona
vand the fruit can make you extremely
bloated it can bother a lot of people's
stomach so one amazing alternative here
blend it into a smoothie this is
actually also better for digestion
because
basically when you're blending you're
pre-digesting your food so anything
that's more liquid is going to get
digested and absorb better into your
body than when it's solid so you're
getting more nutrients but don't
underestimate using water while I am
also a total smoothie fan there are a
few things that Dr Mona mentions in her
kind of
Ode to smoothies here that I don't
completely agree with for normal healthy
eaters there's not a lot of evidence to
suggest that liquefying Foods measurably
improves nutrition status or reduces
bloating anecdotally however I do
sometimes hear that it can help with
bloating but if this sounds like you it
might be because a you're dealing with
some IBS symptoms and therefore
excessive amounts of fiber could be
irritating so pre-digesting that fiber
in a blender May theoretically help or B
you're healthy but you're not chewing
your food enough this is a surprisingly
common problem interestingly smoothies
come with a lot of hidden bloating risks
as well if you're drinking your smoothie
through a straw or chugging it back in
big gulps it's very common to swallow
air and in fact ninety percent of gas in
your gut is just swallowed air another
thing that is not considered here is
that chewing your food gives your body
more time to secrete gastric digestive
enzymes which should also Aid in better
digestion eating Foods in solid form can
also be more physically and emotionally
satiating once that he found that
liquids don't give you the same
satiation factor as solids even for the
same amount of calories likely because
the act of chewing itself clearly tells
the brain that you're eating calories
while Dr Mona recommends a smoothie
because she says that you know you can
better absorb the nutrients we also
don't want food to pass right through us
either smoothies are technically
pre-digested which means we'll absorb it
faster that being said when we miss out
on that extra step of digestion that our
body is trained to do you'll likely end
up with an empty tank pretty quickly
foods that pass right through us like
simple sugars in a smoothie can cause a
spike in our blood sugar and leave us
susceptible to overeating shortly after
finally I want to flag Dr Mona's comment
about getting more nutrients from a
smoothie by blending it with water this
is where Dr Mona is kind of teetering
into the wooy food combining territory
Dr Mona's Theory here is that if you
eliminate nutrient-dense liquids like
milk and instead blend your fruit with
water the fruits will be better and more
effectively absorbed and you'll get more
nutrients out of it this is based on the
food combining Theory principle that if
you give your body too many
nutrient-dense foods it will slow down
digestion and the absorption of
nutrients will be also slowed so if you
eliminate the number of nutrient-dense
foods and you swap in water for your
smoothie Dr Mona believes that you can
reap more of the nutrients from the
fruit obviously there's no scientific
proof to confirm any of this I think
we've already squashed this myth pretty
well right here in fact the best way to
maximize your smoothie situation and get
more nutrients out of it is to add more
nutrients so instead of nutrient-free
water maybe add some healthy fats from
avocado or nut butter or protein from
Greek yogurt or tofu or soy milk that is
certain to increase the nutrient value
of your drink now the internet is Rife
with competing suggestions so if the
fruit only smoothie isn't your jam why
not a fruit free diet but only if you
are farther away from the equator no
sugar around five grams or under is okay
the thing is the closer you watch the
Equator the more fruits you're able to
eat but the further away you go the less
you should be consuming because it's not
natural for fruits to be in that area so
just because it's healthy in some areas
of the world doesn't make it healthy in
other areas of the world wow there's a
lot to tackle in like just a minute
worth of footage the strangest thing
about her recommendation is that she
goes on to say that the closer you are
to the Equator the more fruits you can
eat but the further away you live the
less fruit you can eat because it's not
natural for fruits to grow there uh that
is so misinformed and like so unusual I
had to listen to it back five times or
more to really grasp what she was saying
first of all humans have evolved to find
ways to enjoy a variety of fruits and
vegetables to make it easier and more
enjoyable to me are varied nutrient
needs this includes flash freezing
fruits when they're ripe and out of
season that we can enjoy it later on in
the year also I live in Canada and we
live nowhere near the equator so does
that mean that I shouldn't have any
fruit the reality is we grow a lot of
beautiful fruit outside here in Canada
we've got apples and pears in the fall
and strawberries and peaches in the
summer Etc and if we look back in
history our first Nations ancestors
relied on freshly foraged wild berries
as quick nutrient-dense Fuel and we eat
all of these local fruits despite the
fact that again we live 7 000 kilometers
away from the equator girl this series
just doesn't hold up and finally another
theory that just doesn't quite hold up
let's talk about the time former vegan
Elise Parker turned carnivore you may be
wondering but what about the body's
nutritional needs won't you lack some of
the necessary vitamins and minerals that
a more balanced diet can provide well
actually most of the advocates for the
carnivore diet claim that meat contains
all of the vitamins and minerals that
your body needs to not only survive but
to stress I want to flag this point
because this is not necessarily true yes
you can get a variety of vitamins and
minerals from meat however there is one
that is particularly important that you
might be missing out on in significant
amounts and that is vitamin C and let's
not forget about fiber meat doesn't give
us any fiber and that's a shame because
fiber can do a lot for our health not
only has fiber been linked to improving
cardiovascular health by lowering blood
pressure and cholesterol fiber also
promotes a diverse gut microbiome which
improves our immune system digestion
satiety and regularity now many
proponents of a carnivore diet will cite
cultures that have historically eaten
just meat and were not deficient in any
vitamins and minerals like the Inuit for
example however you won't find certain
Meats eaten by the Inuit like whale fat
for example in your standard butcher box
or local Butchery they've also been able
to avoid vitamin deficiencies like
scurvy because they typically consume
whale skin which is rich in collagen and
vitamin C and these Specialty Meats may
be particularly hard to find depending
on where you live well folks I am pretty
sure we have enough examples of
problematic diet tips on this app for me
to create another 4 000 YouTube videos
but I hope you guys enjoyed this little
Roundup of some of the most idiotic
nutrition claims that we have seen on
this app thus far I'm hoping that we can
all Channel our thoughts and prayers
into a future without content like this
I mean I would love to retire at some
point but I'm pretty sure I cannot do
that in a world where we're still
fighting over whether we should be
eating only meat or only fruit but
anyways on that note if you guys like
this video please give us a thumbs up
also leave me a comment below some of
the craziest diet culture tips that you
have seen on the this app or online in
general I'm always loving that we can
unpack this and learn together and don't
forget to subscribe and hit my
description for my free Hunger crush and
combo debuff and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]